[Music]
well hello dear friends uh we want to
welcome you to this program I'd like to
know a question and answer program where
uh those who watch the program send us
their questions and we do the research
and then we do everything possible to
provide an answer that is based on the
Bible and the spirit of Prophecy as well
uh we're happy that you decided to join
us and by the way we're also greatly
appreciate the fact that many of you
support us with your prayers and support
us also financially uh because uh these
programs are made possible because of
the donations that we receive from those
who believe in our mission and believe
in the message that Secrets unsealed is
sharing with the world I have with me
Pastor David Salasar uh he is the CEO of
the Spanish work here at Secrets
unsealed and some TV uh he does an
excellent work here with us and it's
always a pleasure to work with him here
on our program I'd like to know thank
you Pastor Bor is always an honor and a
privilege to work with you in this
program as well praise the Lord uh let
me give you the electronic address where
you can send your questions to us it'll
be on the uh screen TVM tv.org once
again TV tvsm tv.org we'd be delighted
to receive your questions just remember
that we receive many many more questions
than we can answer in one program uh so
we put them all in line and as soon as
we get to yours we will provide an
answer on the air so once again thank
you for being with us and we want to
begin with the word of pray prayer never
should we open God's word without asking
the Lord for his guidance so I want to
ask Pastor Salasar to please have a word
of prayer for us absolutely let us pray
heavenly father as we come before you at
this hour we thank you for allowing us
to uh approach the throne of grace and
by faith we know that we can receive the
promise of the Holy Spirit to not only
be able to understand and to remember
the things you have spoken but also to
give us the light and the right
understanding and the knowledge that
will give answers to the questions that
have been sent I pray that you will use
us uh that we may be your instruments
and that the answers May bring uh a real
blessing and a knowledge of Truth to
those that are watching and listening we
pray this in Jesus name amen amen well
you know in our last program uh we had a
question where we were not able to fully
answer it because we ran out of time uh
this program only only lasts like 25
minutes so and that's every week so we
want to return to that question and
amplify a little bit more in our answer
and I want to repeat the question it's
from Rene uh we don't know exactly
where'r is from he doesn't mention that
but this is the
question uh I am writing in regards to
Acts
4:12 neither is there salvation in any
other for there is none other name under
Heaven given among men where thereby we
must be saved so we're only saved in the
name of Jesus my question is will my
friends who are atheists and Idol
worshippers be saved they are good
people and following the light which
they have many thanks for answering this
question uh so the question basically uh
is whether individuals who do not claim
the name of Jesus will be saved and uh
we could extend that to atheists and
idolators and even people who have never
heard the name of Jesus like for example
I I would imagine that the majority of
the Muslim world has never even heard
the name of Jesus uh so uh how are those
people saved if people are saved in the
name of Jesus that's the question so
what can we say well Pastor uh let's go
to the Book of Romans I think it's an
important uh starting point to answer
this question fully
there in the chapter 1 verse
20 uh Paul's speaking of those who have
not known the gospel who have not
received the knowledge of Jesus per se
he says this for the invisible things of
him speaking of Christ from the creation
of the world are clearly seen being
understood by the things that are made
even his eternal power and godhead so
that they are without
excuse so here he lays out
this you know this assumption or this
declaration that those who have not
necessarily been exposed to the
knowledge of the scriptures or the
knowledge of the of the word of God the
evidence of God is seen in the things
that are made through
creation they the human race as a whole
have the ability have the possibility to
understand understand and to know the
Creator even the godhead as he mentions
so they are without an excuse to know
about the God in heaven they may again
may not know the details may not even
know the name of Jesus per se but the
understanding of God and the godhead is
revealed through creation if they are
willing to to to see you know the
evidences of creation that points them
to the Lord and to the Creator yeah you
know in Romans 2 to the Apostle Paul
continues addressing this particular
Point uh in verse 14 he says for when
Gentiles who do not have the law it's
talking not only about the Ten
Commandments but also the whole Old
Testament economy who have not the law
uh By Nature do the things in the law
these although not having the law are a
law to themselves uh so I want to read a
statement from uh the right of Ellen
White uh Desire of Ages 638 it's in the
chapter on unto one of these the least
my brethren um and uh it's a powerful
statement Those whom Christ commends in
the Judgment may have known little of
theology so not only Scholars are going
to be saved right right of course but
they have cherished his principles MH
through the influence of the Divine
Spirit they have been a blessing to
those about them even among the Heathen
we call them pagans these days even
among the Heathen are those who have
cherished the spirit of kindness before
the words of Life have fallen upon their
ears they have befriended the
missionaries even ministering to them at
the Peril of their own lives you know
we're reminded of Rahab in Jericho
absolutely uh you know she'd heard about
what God had done for Israel crossing
the Red Sea the plagues and everything
but she was from a pagan nation and so
once again uh before the words of Life
had fallen upon their ears they have
befriended the missionaries even
ministering to them at the Peril of
their own lives among the Heathen once
again the pagans are those who worship
God ignorantly those to whom the light
is never brought by human
instrumentality yet they will not perish
though ignorant of the written law of
God they have had heard his voice
speaking to them in nature and have done
the things that the law required their
works are evidence that the Holy Spirit
has touched their hearts and they are
recognized as the children of God Desire
of Ages
638 and so god holds us accountable for
the light that we have received and the
use that we make of that light It's Not
By the Light we've received only right
it's by the use of the light that we
have received it would be unjust for God
to expect uh Muslims who have never
heard of Jesus uh to confess the name of
Jesus
overtly many of them I'm sure are living
the principles because the holy spirit
is working on their hearts right and
they will not perish according to the
spirit of Prophecy absolutely pastor and
another thing that you know as the our
friend Greene
mentioned he knows these people and if
they're living to the light that they
have received we have that confidence
now I have a question that I would like
to ask Rene in a sense you know if he is
friends with
them they have now the ability to know
the truth through or more truth or
brighter understanding of the light
through the influence of this friend of
R so if for example he ministers to them
serves them is a friend to them and he
has an opportunity to speak of the truth
of the word of God to speak of Christ to
them then now they have a a a choice to
make and they no longer are without an
excuse to say I never heard of Jesus so
in those scenarios if they reject that
light then they're rejecting of course
the truth and in that sense they will
not be able to be safe because they
actually rejected the light so I think
that it's important and I believe
believe the world has become so much
more connected Pastor you know through
social media internet all those things
that it's very hard to say now with the
influence of the friendships that we can
make with Multicultural people you know
different places I think that we
are having the opportunity now to really
share of the truth to the world and so I
I will pray and I will encourage Rene to
extend out and ask the Lord to give him
the ability to share the truth because
again if they had the opportunity to
listen and they reject that then is on
them but also is on him if he's not
looking for ways to show them greater
light than they have yeah there
definitely will not be atheists and
idolators in heaven yes
exactly uh to to use the Expressions
that are in the question um you know
there are some countries where there is
no access to to the internet uh you know
think for example of China where it's
censored tremendously
I'm sure that there among the hundreds
of millions or more than a billion
people who live in China probably most
of the people haven't even heard the
name of Jesus uh but uh but this person
I think is writing from one of the
Western countries and these individuals
uh you know they have access to the
Bible and they have access to to his
example as you're mentioning yeah and so
only God
knows uh whether they have re rejected
the opportunity because God is going to
hold us also accountable for the
opportunities we have and we didn't take
advantage of those opportunities
absolutely and so I'm glad that all of
these things are going to be in God's
hands amen and by the way this is the
purpose of the investigative judgment
right purpose of the investigated
judgment is to see you know whether
people uh took advantage of all the
light that they received whether a
person who professed Christ truly was
was connected with Christ so God is
going to sort all of this out in the
Judgment I'm glad he's the judge praise
the Lord because we're going to be uh
100% uh agreed with God that every
decision that he made was the right
decision in fact we're going to spend a
thousand years having the opportunity to
to examine the records and uh the
purpose why God allows uh that judgment
to go forward is because he when the
controversy ends he wants to make sure
that there are no Loose Ends amen that
we agree that every single case that God
decided was just and loving amen amen
amen through that uh you know this kind
of reminds me of um in sou the southern
part of
Venezuela there is um there are the
Indians the they're called the Davis
Indians uh they um many many of them are
seventh day avenus in many whole
villages in fact are seventh day avenus
and it's interesting the way that the
gospel went to them uh the chief many
many uh decades ago had a dream uh and
in that dream he saw a man dressed in
white you know missionaries used to
dress in white with u with kind of the
helmet on the head and uh and in his
dream he saw a pastor Davis he he was
tall and he was clothed in white and he
had a black book in his hand and he was
told in his dream uh that um whenever
this Minister came that they were
supposed to listen to him to the message
that he
had and um and also in the dream he saw
that they needed to clean up the village
they needed to not allow the chickens
and the pigs to go through their uh
through their uh homes and that they
were supposed to keep the seventh day
Sabbath you know you can read this in
the book by Bonton hearnden it's called
the seventh day right uh you probably
can get it on Amazon it's out of print
many years ago and U and so the chief
did exactly what he saw in his dream and
uh sometime later Pastor Davis came
walking up to the Village wow with uh
his white clothing and his black book
and today the fruit is the Davis Indians
in that re region of Columbia of
Venezuela so the point that I'm trying
to make is that us
westerners do not have a monopoly on the
Holy Spirit you just because we have the
book just because we have the Bible
doesn't mean that we have the inside
track so to speak in fact God is going
to hold us more accountable absolutely
than they because we've had so much more
light than they have had amen wow okay
well we didn't uh plan to spend this
much time this particular question but I
think it's an important question
absolutely and I hope that uh you know
the insights that we've added in our
research will be useful to uh Rene who
asked the question amen okay our next
question uh is uh regarding the Heavenly
councel MH it comes to us from Germany
from klous good German name klouse yes
uh dear Pastor bore it would be so great
if you could share your knowledge with
me on the following questions I'm very
interested in the Heavenly Council who
are the members of the council what
exactly is the function of the council
is it their duty to advise to give
advice to God or to whom do they give
advice advice do they judge on every
human being is it possible that the
council can outvote God when God thinks
that their opinion is
appropriate uh or appropriate or
inappropriate uh so thank you so much
for your answers so this question has to
do with the Heavenly
Council uh and um how does God operate
the universe it's got a dictator that
sits on his throne and say you do this
you do that and there's actually no
democracy or does God run a type of
government where uh where his creatures
have a say in what goes on Pastor well
you know this is a good question that
you point and the Bible starts
explaining this concept A little in
detail of how the Lord operates his
rulership is the way that he rules the
universe and in in the Book of Job we
have that kind of and view of of this
Council this heavenly Council in the
Book of Job chapter 1 we have verse 6
and seven we have these two verses that
I will read and and just to kind of set
up the the scenario of how it works in a
sense it says there now there was a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and Satan
came also among them and the Lord said
unto Satan whence comest thou then Satan
answered the Lord and said from going to
and fro in the earth and from walking up
and down in it MH so we actually see
that there is this counil if you will
this is the I guess the first part in
the Bible uh that speaks of this Cel
setting where the Lord grants a chance
for the sons of God and we're going to
probably work in details more into what
they are but these are the experience
where God allows his
representatives of other worlds to come
before him before the Heavenly court
before the angels to discuss to hear the
plans to hear perhaps the way that the
Lord
is acting in behalf of his people his
children it's like an open setting the
Lord is transparent he's not like you
said the dictator he's actually
asking Lucifer even though he knows or
Satan he knows where he's coming from he
asks asking he ask he puts this position
of willing to hear and and and be able
to have a conversation with his sons and
Lucifer Satan is actually the only one
that is in Rebellion but the
same treatment that he gives Satan I'm
sure he gives everybody else so he's an
Open Door sort of speak you know uh
ruler where you can actually talk with
him and discuss with him and this is the
first part that you know explains in the
Bible but as we know and I have you
probably can spend on this a little more
expand on this but I have a spirit
prophecy quote that actually talks about
how the council is in heaven so yeah
okay um I just wanted to mention that
there in the Book of Job the passage
that you referred to um these these
members of the Heavenly Council don't
live
there in the presence of God because it
says they came to present themselves
before the Lord mhm and and in Chapter 2
you have a second meeting and it says
that they came again MH to the presence
of the Lord so they must have gone back
to where they came from right if they
come again right uh Ellen White and I'm
probably pretty certain that this is the
statement that uh you were planning on
reading is it the one from Desire of
Ages yes okay why don't you read that
statement from Desire of Ages where it's
speaking about the Ascension of Christ
right uh go ahead and read read it it
says there in the page
834 it says the following there is the
throne and around it the rainbow of
promise there are the Kims and seraphim
the commanders of the Angel's host the
sons of God the representatives of the
unfallen worlds are assembled the
Heavenly Council before which Lucifer
had accused God and his son the
representatives of those sinless Realms
over which Satan had thought to
establish his Dominion all are there to
welcome the Redeemer they're eager to
celebrate his Triumph and to glorify
their
King so so there's several interesting
things here uh many times Ellen White
repeats the same thought in three
different ways yes so so when it says
when Jesus ascends it says there is the
throne right and the father's on the
throne and around it the rainbow of
Promise mhm there are cherubim and
seraphim MH we know those are angels
right and then it says the commander of
the Angel
hosts the sons of God there's uh you
have job involved there the sons of God
the representatives of the unfallen
worlds those are three ways of saying
the same thing the commanders of the
Angel hosts the sons of God the
representatives of the unfallen worlds
are assembled and then it says the
Heavenly Council before which Lucifer
had accused God and his son the
representatives of those sinless Realms
over which Satan had thought to
establish his Dominion all are there to
welcome the Redeemer so clearly there
are other worlds and each world has its
representative right and each
representative uh actually is a member
of the Heavenly Council so God has kind
of like a republic doesn't he it seems
that way exactly a representative system
of government and uh and by the way the
first time that we know of where God God
uh called The Heavenly counsel was in
Lucifer sin exactly because God got all
of the Heavenly uh Representatives
together this is in Patriarchs and
Prophets the first chapter and God the
Father explained the position of his son
before the Heavenly Council and Elway
goes on to say that the decision to
expel Satan from heaven was not
unilateral by God but the Heavenly
Council said he needs to be expelled mhm
M uh so now could God do this all on his
own of course God could do it on his own
he's God right right but God wants us to
see that he cares what we think he he
Delights to hear our our Expressions
right and and so uh God is not a
dictator who sits on his throne and says
you do this you do that and don't do
this and don't do that God cares what we
think
and he Delights in hearing our opinion
absolutely because also the Lord Pastor
you know as you are mentioning here he's
he Delights in his creatures in his
creation to follow or reflect his own
character so he is eager to see the same
principle that governed his own person
how the law of God is a transcrip of his
own character he wants that experience
to be ref reflected to be part of his
creatures so when he sees those that he
has made to follow and to think like him
to to to see the beauty of love to the
Lord of love to fellow men to you know
to have that those those principles in
their own life then he knows that their
decisions are going to be his own
decisions so they're really in agreement
and God is not forcing them to think
that way it's just their own choice of
loyalty to the Lord loyalty to his law
to his character that allows them to
think in the same in harmonious way yeah
I want to recommend because we don't
have time time is running out uh that
those who are watching look up second
Chronicles chapter 18h which is another
example of the Heavenly Council right
there uh God says who's going to
convince Ahab to go to battle so he gets
killed nobody wanted to do it right but
it said that a spirit appeared before
the Lord which is Satan and he said I'll
do it and God says how will you do it he
says well I'll be a I'll be a lying
spirit in the mouths of all the
prophets well we know that that was not
a faithful Angel no of course it was
Satan because God doesn't use lies to
convince a king to go to battle so he
gets killed and so read that story it's
in 2 Chronicles chapter 18 it is a
fascinating story about how there is
deliberation
in the Heavenly Council right uh there's
there's a give and take it doesn't mean
that there's disagreement unless Satan
is there of course well folks our time
has flown by I trust that uh our uh
answers to the questions have jogged
your thinking processes and uh we want
to remind you to please tune in to this
program every week we have new questions
uh we don't repeat the same old
questions thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you next time God bless
and have a have a nice
[Music]
day